it is true I do think one of my most
important credentials for being here
today is having been a Yale
undergraduate I was so excited when
Jamie invited me to participate in this
in this class because it really sort of
brings it full circle in addition to
being the mother of a child with autism
I also have an older brother with autism
and I know that many of you in this
class are also siblings of individuals
with autism so I think that we have a
lot in common and I hope you take some
time to talk about the specific role of
siblings I'm not really going to talk
about that today but it's such an
important topic and really just very
much in need of more study siblings are
probably the least studied area in in
autism advocacy so really why are we
here today because autism now affects
about one in a hundred children versus
the fact that about 15 years ago only
one in 10,000 were diagnosed with autism
so that means that in this country alone
every 18 minutes another child is
diagnosed with autism which means that
autism is more prevalent than childhood
diabetes Down syndrome and childhood
cancer combined and just a few weeks ago
President Obama and the CDC called
autism a national public healthcare
crisis he said the three key areas of
his health care policy were going to be
to focus on heart disease cancer and
autism and we saw some of that change
reflected in some of the new stimulus
grants which I'm going to talk about in
a little while but I also want to point
out that a lot of times when we're
talking about research we tend to forget
that this is what we're talking about
when we're talking about autism we're
talking about children we're talking
about adults and we're talking about
families and sometimes we tend to get a
little bit lost in some of the science
that's surrounding autism but I always
like to think about autism as really a
combination of scientists and families
working together and I'm sure you
recognize
this photo this is one of my favorite
photos I used this photo all the time I
just love how it really shows clinicians
researchers children and even you know
the moms a little bit cut off but the
moms they're all working together to
help individuals with autism so what I'm
going to talk about today is really I'm
gonna just do a quick review of autism
and autism advocacy to make sure that
we're using the same terms and
definitions that I'm going to talk about
how autism affects the entire family not
just the person who's diagnosed with
autism and then I want to spend a little
bit of time focused on why so many
families seem to have become so
distrustful of the science and the
research and how some of that distrust
has really reflected on the care and
treatment that they're able to provide
to their family members so I'm sure by
now at this point in this class everyone
knows autism spectrum disorders are
really a group of developmental
disabilities that encompass classic
autism pdd-nos Asperger's Rhett syndrome
and childhood disintegrative disorder
and that we are looking at individuals
who have impairment and disability
across three core domains social
communication and behavior the question
I've always asked whenever I speak is
what causes autism and honestly we don't
know and that's why there continues to
be so much controversy we know that
there's a strong genetic component or
genomic component as we are starting to
talk about now we know that the
environment plays some role and we know
that because of the twin studies I'm
sure you guys have talked about the twin
studies okay well in general the genetic
studies show that when there are
identical twins who share 100% of their
DNA if one twin is diagnosed with autism
the chances that the other twin will
also be diagnosed with autism is around
90% whereas in fraternal twins we know
that if one child is diagnosed with
autism the chance that the other twin
would also be diagnosed is around 115
one in 15 which is the rate we tend to
see in siblings so we see that there's a
strong genetic
but again 90% is not 100% so we also
know that even with identical twins who
share a hundred percent of their DNA
there's something going on
environmentally we don't know if it's
prenatal or postnatal but something is
happening to trigger autism we also know
that what autism really is at its core
is a developmental trajectory that's
gone awry really due to social
impairments individuals who for whatever
reason are not attending to faces in
early childhood and as a result failed
to develop the expertise that
individuals tend to develop in people
preferring to develop an expertise in
things and this is reflected in a lot of
the face processing again I'm hoping
that you talked about some of these face
processing studies and some of the
atypical brain studies that we see with
individuals with autism we can reliably
diagnose autism by age 3 the DSM 4 says
autism can be done should be diagnosed
by age 3 but because of a lot of the
great work that's going on right here at
Yale and elsewhere we're really able to
push down the age of diagnosis to around
18 months and sometimes we can diagnose
as early as 14 months and the reason
that's so important is because the
earlier we can diagnose the earlier
children can begin to get early
intervention services again diagnosis is
made based on behavior and often made
based on parental questionnaire there's
no medical test for autism and every
child with autism is is different
although they all do seem to share
certain similarities so I though
although I know that dr. volkmar likes
to say if you put a hundred children in
a room all of whom are diagnosed with
autism the first thing you'll notice is
how different they all are I think
you'll also sort of notice that there's
something similar about all of them as
well you may not be able to define
exactly what it is but there's something
that you can sense that is
characteristic of all of them I always
like to talk about the red flags for
autism because our foundation spends a
lot of times they learn the signs of
autism learn the signs of autism so
whenever there's a group together rather
than say learn the signs of autism I
actually like to take two minutes and
say
these are the signs of autism so I think
parents spend a lot of time focused on
the physical milestones when you become
new parents you'll know exactly at what
age a child should roll over sit up
stamp pull up to a standing position at
what age they should start to walk and
at what age they should start to run but
it's just as critical now for us to be
aware of the developmental and
communicative milestones so we get
concerned when a child is not babbling
or cooing by 12 months not pointing at
objects in order to draw someone's
attention to an object they're
interested in by 12 months babies should
respond to their name by about 12 months
we like to see babies saying single
words by about 16 months they should
really be saying two word phrases that
are novel and communicative not just
repeating something that they've heard
in a video or that heard something that
you've said they should really be having
those types of novel utterances by about
2 years of age and any time any child
has any loss of language or any loss of
social skills no matter what age that's
also a red flag for autism then there
are other symptoms and comorbidities
that are typical in children with autism
the first being epilepsy anywhere
between 30 and 50% of kids with autism
are also diagnosed with seizure disorder
or epilepsy a lot of our kids have
issues with sleep many of them are up
all night including my daughter's she
likes to go to bed at 9:00 and get up at
2:00 and she's ready to start her day
but I'm not so becomes that sort of an
issue in our household kids with autism
can tend to get aggressive I know you're
going to be talking about that later on
some of them can also be very withdrawn
we see people with autism who have no
language we also see people with autism
who talk incessantly
so again it's a very heterogeneous
genius diagnosis but there are certain
things we look out for the key point
that I always try to make is that early
intervention is really the best weapon
we have right now against autism kids
can make meaningful games and skills
through early intervention and about
half of them can make enough gains to be
mainstreamed by the time that they're
ready for kindergarten there's some
variation in the research regarding how
well those kids who are mainstreamed do
when they get to middle school and then
have to navigate the social dynamics of
the middle school cafeteria which I
think even for a person without a
disability is it's often challenging but
for kids who are in a strong early
intervention program by strong I mean
about 40 hours a week of solid
one-on-one intervention between the time
that their age three and five the
research is showing that between 30 and
50% of them are able to go on to
mainstream kindergarten an early
intervention program is really very
state-by-state
unfortunately the services that your
child will receive depends tremendously
on where you live
which school district you live in which
state you live in
which is in my opinion something that we
need to change and I'm assuming that
you're also familiar with the
individuals with Disabilities Act which
is really the legislation that was
passed in the 1970s that said our kids
are entitled to an education at all back
when my brother was diagnosed in the
1960s there was no I DEA my mother was
told that they can't teach kids like him
and he ended up in Willowbrook
so fortunately now we have laws that
protect our children and we have
wonderful teachers who want to work with
our children and our children can learn
and they can make games they learn
differently but they can learn
the treatments for autism very far and
wide there are some that are backed by
good evidence and there are many that
are anecdotal and can only be described
as totally off-the-wall some that have
the benefit of evidence behind them are
applied behavior analysis therapy or ABA
therapy speech therapy occupational
therapy physical therapy strong social
skills training there's some good
pharmacological treatments that have
good studies behind them now some
studies show that they're efficacious
and just as important are the studies
looking at different pharmacological
interventions that are not efficacious
that's just as important for parents to
know we need to know what doesn't work
as much as we need to know what does
work then there's a whole range of other
treatments that don't have any science
behind them and can often harm children
as much as they could possibly help them
and among these are music therapy
special diets
secretin injections anti yeast agents
chelation which is an attempt to extract
heavy metals from a child's body the
idea there being that if mercury might
cause autism then extracting the mercury
from their body might help them to be
cured the problem there is that the
chelating agents extract all metals
including calcium that you need for your
heart to function so we've actually had
a death of a child who was undergoing
chelation therapy I get probably two or
three emails a day touting new and
amazing cures for autism I got one
honestly just an hour before we started
this presentation that indicates that
marijuana is a fine treatment for kids
with autism
this data these data are from the
interactive autism Network which is a
project that's at Kennedy Krieger and
this graph indicates the number of
treatments that kids tend to be on at
any one time what you'll notice is that
the meeting is about five so and these
are simultaneous treatments so what this
graph is really showing is that about
half of our kids are on at least five
treatments and then you'll see I can't
people want me to stay on stuff okay
this graph actually extends way out here
there's one child in the survey who was
on fifty six simultaneous treatments and
given that there's evidence for maybe
five or six treatments it's a little
scary to me to see that our children are
being put through these untested untried
treatments because you know at the end
of the day this is one of this is one of
our children and this is one of our kids
and this is a particularly beautiful kid
with autism that's that's my daughter
but this is not one of our children and
they deserve to be treated better than
to be guinea pigs for individuals who
think that they happen to know the cure
like try giving your child marijuana and
he might improve okay
we'll see but in general I think one of
the reasons that parents try some of
these treatments that have no basis in
evidence is really because we love our
kids so much we want them to get better
and we aren't often in extremely
vulnerable States when your child is
diagnosed with a disorder as as
challenging as autism is and we become
very vulnerable to charlatans who are
peddling snake oil and the Cure d'Azur
as I call it sometimes you feel well it
couldn't hurt to try this but it can
because a lot of times I will hear from
parents who say that rather than
starting applied behavior analysis
therapy which is an evidence-based
treatment they're going to try vitamin
therapy for six months and see how it
goes
and those are six months that that child
will never get back when applied
behavior analysis therapy could actually
have made a difference in the
developmental trajectory of that child's
life so whereas yeah probably giving
your child vitamin b12 for six months
it's not going to hurt them you are
still robbing them of the opportunity to
make gains in an evidence-based
treatment so autism absolutely affects
the entire family and not just the
person with autism there is an impact on
marriage on siblings grandparents many
of our parents report depression as I
was saying there's a try anything
attitude and see what works because we
love our children so much and we just
are willing to try anything there's
tremendous financial costs associated
with autism in many states there's no
insurance coverage for even
evidence-based treatments associated
with autism only 15 states in the United
States offer insurance coverage for
applied behavior analysis therapy so
often parents are paying for these
therapies out-of-pocket and it can run
upwards of a hundred thousand dollars a
year so parents are mortgaging their
house moving out of their house moving
in with their in-laws in order to pay
for therapy for their their children
often one parent also has to leave his
or her job usually it's her job because
of the fact that the children need
constant supervision one parent really
has to organize the therapy schedule in
my family that was me I used to say that
I became the CEO of Jodi Inc Jodi's my
daughter's name I had to hire therapists
I had to get them paid I had to buy them
supplies it became a full-time job so
just at the time when your medical bills
are getting larger your family is down
one income
a lot of new data is really showing that
the parents of children with autism in
fact have more stress than parents of
typical children which is expectable
expected but also parents of children
with other disabilities and the research
is showing that distress is in fact
related to the behavioral problems
associated with children with autism as
opposed to cognitive functioning which
is more ubiquitous across the spectrum
of all disabilities a study last year
showed that a lot of the stress was
related to the child sleep problems and
there's one that I can relate to when I
get three hours of sleep a night my
stress level is through the roof is much
harder for me to take care of my child
when I've had two or three hours of
sleep than when I've had a full night's
sleep really interesting paper this year
from the University of Tel Aviv showed
that a lot of the stress that parents of
children with autism face is because of
a lack of resolution with the diagnosis
and what they mean by that is that some
parents I think every parent is
devastated when they first get the
diagnosis but some parents are able to
reconcile it and and get on with their
life and accept that their child is
going to have challenges but continue to
have as close to a normal existence as
possible
more quickly than other parents are I
think this study showed that the median
time towards to resolution was four
years so what that's saying is it takes
about four years until you sort of get
past a lot of the grief and devastation
and are ready to accept your child and
love them for the skills that they have
and appreciate all the wonderful things
that they still have to offer most
parents do get to that point
it takes some longer than others others
get stuck and they never accept their
child and those tend to be the parents
who continued throughout the child's
life with this try anything attitude and
put
through a lot of therapies that are not
only painful but harmful the 2008 study
that looked specifically at parents of
children with autism compared to to
parents of children with Down syndrome
and parents of children with autism were
shown to have lower perceived confidence
in their own parenting more frustration
more anxiety and tenseness more social
isolation less social support more
paranoia and hostility and they in
general found parenting to be less
rewarding and again a lot of this was
based on the behavioral issues you know
when you're in constant fear that your
child is going to have a meltdown in a
restaurant or take food off other
people's plate or go into the
supermarket and spend that time removing
the cereal boxes from the shelves and
that's a very stressful situation that
my daughter when we would take her to
the supermarket used to like to spend
her time taking the cereal off the
shelves and then putting it back and
you'd be amazed at how nasty people are
when they see a ten year old child who's
behaving in a socially inappropriate way
their first inclination is that I'm just
a bad mom it's not people's first
inclination to think that that may be a
child with a developmental disability so
the results is that a lot of parents say
I'm just not going to take her I'm gonna
leave her home I'll get a babysitter
when I have to go to the supermarket
they avoid that situation or they
themselves stay home
I want to talk a little bit more about
some of the specific issues that are
causing stress for parents and these are
additional data from the Ian project I
talked a little bit about the Ian
project before it's the interactive
autism network this is a project at the
Kennedy Krieger Institute at Johns
Hopkins this is a database with about
10,000 parents in it it was put together
for the purpose of gathering information
about parents of children with autism so
that those children could be enrolled in
clinical trials and studies but it's
become an incredibly rich source of
information about parenting specifically
parenting children with autism because
the parents have to fill out very
extensive questionnaires so they've
really been able to uncover a lot of
very rich data so make sure right so
first of all looking at the sources of
stress 72% and let me let me just go
back and say that these data are based
on about 3,700 mothers and 340 fathers
so that alone sort of gives you a little
hint of who is really taking the lion's
share of the parenting responsibilities
and I also want to point out that all of
these data are based on self reporting
by parents so you need to keep that in
mind as you're evaluating the data
that's all self-reported but looking at
sources of stress 72% of the parents in
the Ian's Network described their
child's behavior as a major source of
stress the more extreme the behaviors
and the more unpredictable the behaviors
the tougher the challenge and meltdowns
and aggression were both cited both
because they require a hyper vigilance
on the part of the family and they make
interaction with the outside world very
difficult this results as I said in
social isolation and parents who decide
just to stay home because that's easier
than risking their child having a
meltdown
and again as I described in my own
situation parents also cited rude
comments made by other people as a
tremendous source of stress we had 48%
of the families in e'en reporting that
their child's sleep habits were a
tremendous source of stress kids with
autism often refused to sleep like my
daughter they'd wake up in the middle of
the night ready to start their day or
many of them for whatever reason that we
don't yet understand require extremely
little sleep and this results in the
parents sleep being a very short
duration and and also of poor quality
even when my daughter is asleep I'm
worried about what's gonna happen if she
wakes up and I stay asleep is she going
to leave the house is she going to get
into a situation where she might hurt
herself
so even when she's sleeping and I'm
trying to sleep it's not that same kind
of high quality sleep that you're able
to get when you completely turn off
almost 70% of parents reported stress as
a result of difficulty getting
treatments for their child with autism
organizing therapy finding treat finding
therapists hiring the therapist paying
for the therapists organising doctor's
appointments and medications fighting
with insurance companies fighting with
the school district and really just
worrying about their child's behavior
while at school we'll all were all sort
of cited as a source of family stress
and then there's always disappointment
associated with treatments that don't
pan out or don't work the way you
expected them to or we're told that they
might 46% of the families and ian's
reported stress from the fact that the
therapies that they truly expected were
going to work didn't work they felt very
cheated they felt cheated of both money
and time and they also reported a lot of
stress when family members or their
friends criticized either their choice
of treatment or the fact that their
child had not made much progress again
they 10 pair intend to interpret that as
blaming the mother
autism is often described described
really as two steps forward and one step
back all kids with autism seem to
experience setbacks re-emergence of a
bad behavior that you thought you had
squashed or the onset of seizures when a
child is either 5 or when they enter
puberty is often a tremendous source of
stress I I remember particularly our
neurologist told me that since my
daughter had reached age 5 without
having had a seizure we were out of the
woods about two weeks later she had her
first seizure so there's really no such
thing as out of the woods there's
statistically out of the woods but for
every parent there's really no out of
the woods and when they'll setback
happen when those setbacks happen
there's sort of a rien sub the grief
that you experienced when your child was
first diagnosed and sometimes these
setbacks also require you to find a new
school for your child if it's a
particularly challenging behavior or to
find a new type of therapy or a new
therapist to provide the intervention I
really don't know any parent of a child
with autism who doesn't worry about
what's going to happen when they're no
longer there to take care of their child
himself
we all worry about whether our children
will be able to find jobs whether
they'll be happy whether there will be
people in their lives who will love them
we worry about our other children will
they be the ones who will need to take
care of them will they be equipped to
take on the schools and Medicaid and all
of the agencies that are required and is
that fair for us to ask of our
non-disabled children that they be the
ones to take this on so I think we spend
an inordinate amount of time and I think
the number there is something uh eighty
nine eighty nine percent of parents
spend a lot of time worrying about their
child's future
so really based on all this data on all
of this dress that parents are under
what is it that we really need for one
thing we need a much more compassionate
community and that comes with awareness
and I think we've seen some improvements
there we've certainly seen heightened
awareness over the last few years of
autism we absolutely need insurance
coverage and there's been some progress
there as well in the last few years more
states have passed mandatory insurance
coverage for evidence-based treatments
for autism we need more educational
professionals to work with our kids in
school we need more therapists but
mostly we need in in my opinion we need
more research because we're not really
going to provide be able to provide our
children with the answers they need and
the improvements in their lives that
they're entitled to without research and
then we also need to do a better job
getting the research that's done into
the field where it can be implemented so
when I talk about research I'm really
focused on research that's yielding
actionable information for parents so
for example we need to know what causes
autism so that we once we understand the
mechanism of action that triggers autism
we'll be able to start to create
targeted therapeutics that could really
intervene in some of those pathways and
we've seen some of that happen now in
the work with fragile X where
information has been gleaned about
specific
what causes fragile X the proteins
associated with the genes assume in
fragile X and compounds have been
developed to dampen down proteins that
are over produced in children with
fragile X and those those compounds are
now in clinical trials the NIH announced
yesterday that they had begun a clinical
trial of a very promising compound that
could really reverse some of the effects
of fragile X so my hope is that we'll be
able to do that with autism as well we
need to know from an evidence-based side
what treatments and interventions work
we also need to know what doesn't work a
study that shows a particular drug is
not efficacious is just as valuable to a
parent as a study that shows what does
work so we had a few years ago those
secretin trials where parents were
injecting their children with a pig
hormone derivative because there had
been anecdotal information that this had
helped some children with autism so with
because there was a lack of evidence on
either side parents said well I have to
try it I owe it to my child to at least
try it
there were several good studies done
secretin was shown to be completely non
efficacious and fortunately now you
don't hear very often every once in a
while you still hear about a child who's
getting secretin injections but by and
large because of that research children
are no longer getting injected with with
pig hormones I think I'm gonna just go
through this very fast in the interest
of time but these are some examples of
really evidence-based studies that are
valuable to parents we had a study that
came out just a few months ago that
looked at incidents of gastrointestinal
symptoms in children with autism we hear
that a lot we hear that while children
with autism have all kinds of GI issues
but the question is do they have GI
issues at a greater rate than children
in the general population
no not that they have GI issues but does
it occur to a greater rate and does it
and therefore is it a clue and what this
study showed was no they don't have GI
issues at a greater rate than children
in the general population we also had a
study that came out a few weeks ago in
June actually two studies
that looked at citalopram or celexa and
also lexapro which is an SSRI SSRIs have
been used on kids with autism and both
of these studies really show that
citalopram was not effective that's
useful information and I think a lot of
times scientists are reluctant to
support to show data that didn't support
the hypothesis but from a parent's point
of view it's just as important for me to
say to know that celexa is probably not
going to help with repetitive behaviors
so that I don't waste time and expose my
daughter to the side-effects of putting
her on celexa so I talked a little bit
about fragile X we also had a lot of
movement in Rett syndrome again really
using novel compounds to target the core
symptoms and showing improvement in
learning capability even in adult mice
so that was a tremendously exciting
paper for me because it really shifted
our the whole way we think about
developmental disability so I'm just
gonna skip through that but I think
given that so much of the science is
clear and so much is unknown about
autism why is it that in society today
parents in general are reluctant to
believe the science and there continues
to be this discord in the autism
community regarding what we need to
study how we should study it and how we
should treat our children and I think a
lot of this there are many sources of
the distrust I think one is the legacy
of the refrigerator mother's theory
which is blame the mom I don't know if
you've talked about the refrigerator
mother theory but that was basically a
theory that said children became
autistic because their mothers were too
cold and couldn't bond with them
properly so their children retreated
into this world of self and stop talking
and showed all these symptoms as a way
to rebel against their mother who was a
bad parent there's still a lot of stigma
associated with having a child with
autism there are still people who think
that there's nothing wrong with your
child that a little better parenting
couldn't take care of that it's really
just a discipline
shoo it's not a organic disability at
all so we do still hear that I think as
we were talking before many families are
continue to be traumatized and desperate
and will try anything I think a lot of
parents are experiencing things that the
science isn't really isn't matching what
the science is saying I think a lot has
to do with the attitudes of some of the
doctors and professionals that parents
have encountered a lot of the
pediatricians have not helped the
parents to feel heard
they've been very dismissive of parents
concerns I think we really need to look
there at a new way for doctors and
parents to communicate and work as
partners in their child's health as
opposed to the doctor playing the role
of parent and the mother playing the
role of child there's definitely a
different degree of Education with
regard to Science in the parent
community we have some parents who are
themselves scientists and researchers
and we have many parents whose
educational level did not include a lot
of rigorous training in the scientific
method we also have a tendency to just
want to tune out all of the thousands of
experts who flood our inbox every day
people just say if there's a thousand
different theories I'll just pick the
one that makes sense
to me if I agree with it so they tend to
tune out the good science because
there's just an overload but I think the
real the two key causative factors for
why families have become distrustful one
is the internet you know the on the
internet all opinions are created equal
anyone can post a blog anyone can start
a scientific journal online so anyone
can now say well this study was
published in a scientific peer-reviewed
journal you really have to look at who
are the peers and where is the journal
published so there's a lot of definitely
a lot of issues with the internet and
then the influence of the media and and
the cult of celebrity where in our
society we have really become more
willing to trust celebrities
then then doctors with regard to the
internet specifically again going back
to Ian data eighty-one percent of
parents that they got information about
autism from the internet and you really
have to wonder about the sites that
they're visiting are they visiting sites
like Yelp Child Study Center or NIH or
CDC or are they visiting sites with less
reputable information that's not
scientifically based like marijuana can
cure my child's autism you should try it
too with regard to the media I mean I
could talk about the media's complicit
nests and it's all day the media one of
the things that bothers me tremendously
about the media is what I and I am as a
member of the media I was a producer at
NBC for 14 years before I became a
professional autism advocate so I I
really blame my colleagues here is
something I that dr. Paul Offit has
called the fallacy of balance which I've
started to refer to as casting in the
media he talks about the fact in his
book autism's false prophets that the
media feel compelled to show both sides
even when both side when two sides are
not supported by the weight of
scientific evidence so with regard
specifically to the vaccine issue
although dozens of studies have failed
to show any sort of causal link between
autism and vaccines when they report on
a new study the media feels compelled to
show a parent who says well I still
think that vaccines cause autism and by
showing two sides of that issue which it
looks to the average person watching
that each side is equally meritorious it
also looks like half the parents feel
one way and half the parents feel the
other when in fact many times is very
hard for CNN or CBS to find a parent
who's willing to say no I I'm not
vaccinating my child because I still
think it causes autism and this is what
I've started to refer to as casting I
will get calls from the media saying I
need a mom in Idaho who doesn't who has
two who has a child with autism and
doesn't vaccinate and I haven't been
able to find one and my response is well
maybe that should tell you something
that you have been able to find one but
they specifically will go out and call
the advocacy groups and say can you find
me a dad who thinks that vaccines cause
autism can you find me a dad who is
thinking of divorcing his wife because
of autism I mean this this is really no
longer news it's become what I've called
casting in general I think the media
likes to defend the weak over the
powerful the media loves Mavericks they
love people whose ideas are crazy are
out there they love to be
anti-establishment
they love to say that they are taking on
big pharma or they are taking on the
government they feel that their
responsibility is to look out for the
little guy and in many ways that's a
very important role for the media to
play but in this case they're really
casting the parts incorrectly and that
it's really the public health system
that's trying to protect our children
and it's the little guy who's trying to
make a buck off unsuspecting parents the
media also loves controversy so anytime
there is a great piece of genetics
research that comes out you'll see no
coverage in the media but whenever
there's any type of story that looks at
mercury or vaccines the media will be
all over that no matter how well done
that study is and it'll just bring the
whole controversy back to light even
though from a scientific standpoint
there is no more controversy there and
then I would say that the media tend to
fall into the single study trap where
whenever there's one study that's
showing something new they love to
report it whether it's usually before
it's been replicated and usually before
there's been an opportunity for the
scientific community to weigh in so one
in particular was the work that was done
by Andrew Wakefield in London where he
reported that children they were
children with autism had measles virus
in their gut and that these this these
measles molecules were leaking out of
their gut and attacking their brain and
causing autism this has never been
replicated the study was actually
retracted from the journal that
published it all of his co-authors
retracted and yet we continue to hear
this this was really the genesis of the
MMR vaccine causes autism hypothesis no
good science behind this all of the
subsequent studies have failed to show
any causal link between MMR and autism
but yet it continues to to rage I'd also
say that the media loves to cast the
love stories that sort of cast the earth
as this toxic environmental wasteland
you know that's become very trendy
everyone thinks that we need to protect
our environment and I'm not saying that
we don't but some people take it to a
crazy extreme like Jenny McCarthy and
Jim Carrey who are saying we have to
green our vaccines you know that's a
nice rhyming phrase but what does it
actually mean to green our vaccines with
vaccines are actually green the only
components in vaccines are those that
need to be there so I'm going to take
two minutes and and just to try to drive
home this this point of how susceptible
people are to this constant need to save
the environment and also so I can stop
talking for two minutes I want I don't
know if any of you have seen this Penn &
Teller video just to set it up for a
second this is they are trying to get
individuals at an environmental rally to
sign a petition and the petition is
actually to ban water and you'll see how
susceptible people are to really
scientific terminology or to anything or
to anyone who's saying I want to save
the environment
to a rally to collect signatures for a
petition she's gonna ask people to sign
a petition banning dihydrogen monoxide
that's dye hydrogen monoxide water
that's right water and she's not gonna
lie or even stretch the truth not at all
she's just gonna talk about what water
is and what it does with vocabulary and
tone of environmental hysteria oh this
is a petition for dihydrogen monoxide
what it is is it the chemical that is
found now in reservoirs and in lakes
pesticides super chronic companies are
using this styrofoam company's nuclear
nuclear companies and now when they use
it of pesticides when we're washing our
fruit and things like that it's not
coming out which of course means that
it's end up in the grocery stores and in
our baby's food and stuff like that
causes excessive sweating accepted
urination these people signs we don't
know if they thought but they sign our
petition woman was getting signatures
left and right okay mostly left but
ma'am there's a lot of people against
that evil water he's passionate inform
people didn't even need to ask what the
hydrogen monoxide is they didn't even
ask is passion supposed to replace
common sense we understand the desire to
join up and do something important it
it's sexy to save the world but it got
to spend a couple of minutes to find out
if you're really saving the world and
not just being herded around by some
politically motivated app who may not
really care that much about the
environment but see this is some chance
to raise money forever they think is a
good idea no end justifies the means of
lying man there were a lot of people who
sign the petition and we're not talking
about handful of dopes we're talking 200
it causes a lot of urination vomiting
can even happen okay
even the head organizer of this rally
signed the petition eagerly and our
petition was still getting signatures
companies like pesticide companies
styrofoam companies nuclear companies
all of these people use it finally we
let our tip should be what sort of water
water should be banned yes
no I don't think so I think we need to
drink water and I don't know what you
mean by what it should be bad water to
know
you set these folks up but it does show
that maybe they're not so much
environmentalists as they are joiners of
anything so I showed that as I said
first to give me a two minutes to stop
talking but really to just show how
susceptible people are to scientific
terminology and how we all want to be
joiners we all want to feel like we
understand in our part of what's going
on and that we're doing what's best
either for the environment here or for
our children even though that's not
really stemming from any sort of
scientific evidence here we were talking
about banning water and people were
eager to do it because they thought that
they were doing something good they
didn't really understand the science
behind how banning water might not be
such a good idea I don't think it's it's
all parents though for I don't want to
put all the responsibility on parents
for why science has not been triumphant
in in the autism arena I think there
have been a lot of missteps by some
agencies one in particular by the
American Academy of Pediatrics in the
way that they announced the news about
removing thimerosal from vaccines I
think they did that in a very scary way
and their attempt to put out a press
release really caused a lot of harm when
the AAP decided to remove thimerosal
from vaccines in back in I think 2001
they did so because they wanted to study
site marisol not because there was any
evidence that thimerosal was causing
autism but they wanted to make parents
feel better they wanted to study site
marisol the phrase they used was to make
safe vaccines safer wealth it was going
to make it safer to remove thimerosal
then maybe they weren't so safe to begin
with so a lot of parents sort of jumped
on this
make vac to make safe vaccine safer as
evidence from the AAP that they know
that they're not safe thus there's this
vast conspiracy between the American
Academy of Pediatrics and the CDC and
the vaccine manufacturers again it's a
lot of times it's parents looking for
what they want to hear and in this case
they heard it I think there's also a lot
of issues with regard to the conflict
conflict of interest with our experts
we've now gotten to the point where
anyone who has an established body of
scholarship on a topic is considered to
have a conflict of interest rather than
to be an expert I mean we've seen this
with judicial nominations and we see it
with our scientists where a lot of
parents are saying well this person has
a pre-established idea about so let's
use vaccines they believe that vaccines
are safe they're not open-minded and
therefore they're no longer qualified to
participate in a conversation about
autism and vaccines as opposed to I'd
say 15 years ago when expertise was
really valued and we look to people who
had spent their lives and careers
studying an area of science and really
look to them to provide guidance and
input I also think that scientists are
at a disadvantage versus parents by the
rhetoric that they're forced to use
because of science and and what parents
are able to say versus what scientists
are able to say so for example a parent
can go on The Oprah Winfrey Show and she
can say my son was fine he got the MMR
shot the light went out of his eyes and
he became autistic and Oprah will say
are you sure the vaccines caused autism
and the mom can say I am sure the
vaccines caused autism
where is a scientist
can never be that definitive you can
never say what doesn't cause something
you can never prove that vaccines don't
cause autism you can only say something
like the body of evidence does not
indicate a causal relationship between
vaccines and autism so then when Oprah
says do vaccines cause autism the
scientist has to say I don't know we
don't know it hasn't we can't prove that
and that's what really puts the
scientist at a disadvantage no good
scientist is ever going to say
definitively we know that vaccines to
cause don't cause autism because you
can't prove the null hypothesis just
like if I were to put on you know if I
were to tie a white sheet around my neck
and jump off the roof I could jump off
five thousand times in five thousand
times I'm gonna I'm not gonna be able to
fly I'm gonna fall and break my leg that
doesn't prove that I can't fly it just
proves that five thousand nine five
thousand times I didn't fly but you
can't say with a hundred percent
certainty that I can't fly
so this is this really puts the
scientists at a real disadvantage when
they're on Larry King or on Oprah and
that the parents can be extremely
definitive and the scientists can and
Jenny McCarthy for example on Oprah said
I really don't need science my science
is at home his name is Evan and that was
her science I say it's also um I'm gonna
skip over some of this I also just want
to point out that it's not only
scientists who have competing interests
oftentimes advocacy organizations have
some conflicts of interest as well and
that they have differing differing goals
so just just a little primer on autism
advocacy in 1997 we had the first parent
based autism advocacy group it was
called the National Alliance for autism
research and then the second one the
same year cure autism now the National
Alliance for autism research was founded
on the
coasts and can was founded on the west
coast in 2005 we had Autism Speaks which
was founded by Bob and Suzanne Wright
that really sort of opened the
floodgates for autism advocacy in 2006
Autism Speaks merged with the National
Alliance for autism research in 2007 it
merged with can there then became this
cry there should only be one voice but
you know I think that's not really what
parents are saying I think there needs
to be room for other voices in 2008
after having told the National Alliance
for autism research that they wanted to
merge with them because they agreed with
their science the NAR founders were
dismissed from Autism Speaks I would say
it's very likely that the founder of can
when his term on the board is over next
month he's also going to be dismissed so
we really have to think it are we better
off now having only one huge autism
advocacy group Autism Speaks is going to
raise about 65 million dollars they'll
fund 30 million dollars in science and
all of that's great but the price for
that it's by having one big group and
having so-called big tent we're all
views are welcome you sometimes have to
give up speaking in favor of the science
the way you raise 65 million dollars is
you have to attract a lot of donors and
the way you attract a lot of donors is
by not saying anything that's gonna piss
off any donors so because there are so
many parents who have differing views
the advocacy groups have had to be quiet
on issues regarding the science because
there are so many parents who still can
don't want to be told what the science
says or who actually come out and say I
don't care what the science says my
science is at home his name is Evan so
you know I think we're going to continue
to see some of this discord remain in
the autism community but the important
thing is that we are moving forward with
autism research we now have a federal
strategic plan for autism research that
where parents are very involved
and giving input as to what needs to be
studied the public participation really
resulted in a very consumer focused
research plan that's really looking at
how we can get information that families
and individuals with autism need it
looks at when should we be concerned
about autism how can we understand
what's happening with autism what's
causing autism what treatments are
available for autism where can I turn
for services and what does the future
hold for when individual individuals
with autism and evety grow up and become
adults you know you are an adult with
autism for a lot longer than you're a
child with autism and yet so much of the
science and energy has really been
focused on the needs of children and
that's that's really changing now so
anyway our foundation was founded we
were founded last year I've been in
Autism Speaks for four years I was
actually the first employee at Autism
Speaks but I felt that I needed to leave
and we needed to start a new
organization that was truly focused on
the science that would not be a big tent
where all views were equally meritorious
whether they were backed by science or
not backed by science but that there
were many many parents who wanted to
speak out for the science and who feel
that we just don't have the funds
available to continue to look at issues
that have questions that have already
been asked and answered and that what
our family members really need and
deserve is the opportunity for new
research that's going to actually yield
useful information to them that's going
to create treatments it's going to help
us understand what causes autism so we
are trying to raise money based on our
science first mission we're supporting
parents and Families by speaking
publicly and getting information about
autism research into the community we
issued our first request for scientific
proposals in September we expect to fund
our first grants in January which will
be less
a year into our operation and we
strongly believe that every dollar
counts so if you want more information
about our foundation it's at autism
Science Foundation org